a lot of pleasantly surprised Rebel fans  right now UNLV football team 3-1 on the  season the last time they won three of  their first four games was in 2008. Mike  Sanford was the coach then before that  it was in 2003 with John Robinson now  they have a chance to move to four and  one with the win over New Mexico on  Friday night the Lobos are well aware of  what's going on in Las Vegas coach Royal  has done a great job recruiting I mean  they've done a really good job in the  transfer portal I mean their running  back is a 6'3 230 pound kid from  Louisville they've been very efficient  they've taken the wall they've taken the  ball away well on defense and they've  given their offense some opportunities  and they've cashed in on them